[Music]
spindly trees rusted gates crumbling
stone a solitary mourner these things
come to mind when we think of cemeteries
but not so long ago
many burial grounds were lively places
with blooming gardens and crowds of
people strolling among the headstones
how did our cemeteries become what they
are today
some have been around for centuries like
the world's largest Wadi al-salam where
more for five million people are buried
but most of the places would recognize
as cemeteries are much younger in fact
for much of human history we didn't bury
our dead at all our ancient ancestors
had many other ways of parting with the
dead loved ones some were left in caves
others in trees were on mountaintops
still others were sunk in lakes put out
to sea ritually cannibalized or cremated
all of these practices though some may
seem strange today
were ways of venerating the dead by
contrast first known burials about a
hundred and twenty thousand years ago
were likely reserved for transgressors
excluding them from the usual right
intended to honor the dead but the first
burials revealed some advantages over
other practices they protected bodies
from scavengers and the elements while
shielding loved ones from the site of
decay these benefits may have shifted
ancient people's thinking toward graves
designed to honor the dead and burial
became more common sometimes these
graves contain practical or ritual
objects suggesting belief in an
afterlife where the dead might need such
tools
communal burials first appeared in North
Africa and West Asia around ten to
fifteen thousand years ago around the
same time as the first permanent
settlements in these areas these burial
grounds created permanent places to
commemorate the dead the nomadic Citians
littered the steps with grave mounds
known as Gorgons the Etruscans built
expensive necropolis their grid pattern
streets lined with tombs in Rome
subterranean catacombs Howl's both
cremation urns and intact remains the
word cemetery or sleeping chamber was
first used by ancient Greeks who built
tombs in graveyards at the edges of
their cities in medieval European cities
Christian Church yards provided rare
open spaces that accommodating the dead
but also hosted markets fairs and other
events farmers even graze cattle in them
believing graveyard grass made for
sweeter milk as cities grew during the
Industrial Revolution large suburban
cemeteries replaced smaller urban Church
yards cemeteries like a hundred and ten
acre parishes in Paris or the
seventy-two acre Mount Auburn in
Cambridge Massachusetts were lushly
landscaped gardens filled with sculpted
stones and ornate tombs once a luxury
reserved for the rich and powerful
individually mark graves became
available to the middle and working
classes people visited cemeteries for
funerals but also for anniversaries
holidays or simply an afternoon outdoors
by the late 19th century as more public
parks and Botanical Gardens appeared
cemeteries began to lose visitors today
many old cemeteries are lonely places
some alluring visitors back with tours
concerts and other attractions but even
as we revive old cemeteries we're
rethinking the future of burial cities
like London New York and Hong Kong are
running out of burial space even in
places where space
so tight cemeteries permanently occupy
land that can't be otherwise cultivated
or developed traditional burial consumes
materials like metal stone and concrete
and can pollute soil and groundwater
with toxic chemicals with increasing
awareness of the environmental costs
people are seeking alternatives many are
turning to cremation and related
practices along with these more
conventional practices people can now
have their remains shot into space used
to fertilize a tree or made into jewelry
fireworks and even tattooing in the
future options like these may replace
burial completely cemeteries may be our
most familiar monuments to the departed
but they're just one step in our
ever-evolving process of remembering and
honoring the dead all living things die
but his resurrection possible and what's
the actual difference between a living
creature and a dead body anyway check
out this lesson to find out
[Music]